I once charged through the Medicaid of
King's Landing I don't want you to be
here heroes do stupid things and they
die
I will return dear Spider one last time
my lady I have to die in this strange
country just like you hey everybody so
you've been requesting my death
predictions for season eight for a long
time so surprisingly there were a number
of main characters that I think that
wound up surviving so what I'll do is
I'll start with the main characters that
I think are gonna crawl away then I'll
start with the characters that I think
we're just gonna be fundamentally
changed so much so that they might as
well be dead then the characters that
are 100% going to bite it by the end so
if you are finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get everything
will be doing season 8 bonus videos till
it gets here and there's giveaway stuff
that I'll talk about at the end of the
video too so characters that are safe
I'll try to explain a little bit about
why I think each of these people will
end up the way they end up and if you
guys really want to I can do separate
videos for the characters themselves so
first off the bat Samwell Gilly and baby
Sam probably the most safe of all the
characters is just not his role to be a
hero do stupid things in charge into
dangers way as Daenerys narrates heroes
do stupid things that get them killed
Samwell is a hero of a different kind
not in the way that Daenerys is talking
about it but then Gendry but not Arya
Arya has an asterisk above her name I
think that she'll climb away but I do
think she'll be one of the characters
that's fundamentally changed paying a
heavy price for the skills that she
gained with the faceless men so that's
actually another important thing to is
the idea of George are Martin talking
about consequences he said that when Jon
Snow was resurrected he would pay a
heavy price for what he went through
like it's not consequence-free like you
can come back as many times as you want
and you'll be completely the same as you
were before no it's not like that the
Lord of Light as Barrack said brought us
back for a reason surely it wasn't to
die of frostbite in the cold so there's
a very specific reason why people that
came back from the dead came back from
the dead but one of the biggest reasons
why I think that she's going to survive
even though she has the Valyrian dagger
so she's definitely going to be fighting
white walkers is is because the whole
thing of season 7 was the lone wolf dies
the pack survives she formed the pack so
she will survive which is also why sanso
is on my list too
she's the Lady of Winterfell that's
pretty much her role so Sansa has proven
that she's actually fairly competent in
managing the north that'll just be what
she continues to do
sur Davos I think will also be a very
good adviser to her which is why I think
that she'll survive he said something
really important this season he said I'm
not much of a fighter so if it comes to
it I won't be much help to you when they
were going back to King's Landing so I
think he's one of those characters that
isn't going to blindly rush into danger
and try and get himself killed in the
name of heroism to save everyone else
even though he's proven time and time
again he's one of the wisest characters
on the show there are a number of
advisor level characters like Tyrion
that I think will survive and Davos is
just one of them so hand in hand with
that Tyrion will survive as well as bran
remember bronze not gonna let anybody
die until he gets what's owed to him
especially Jaime Lannister so bran is
just one of those characters that just
feels so fantastic that he would get
what's owed to him ultimately in the
more traditional heroes of the story
would sacrifice themselves to defeat the
night king like Jaime Lannister I also
think that Brienne is going to be fine
and then you have the Brotherhood
without banners which is sort of what
we're affectionately calling them but
remember their group is getting smaller
by the day so I think the Hound Jorah in
tormund will all survive tormund being
the highest one on that list
now obviously the Hound has a very
specific purpose he's going to help them
defeat the night king but his real
purpose is to defeat the mountain so
then sort of as an intact to that I had
a Daario to the list if he does wind up
coming back I think that he'll survive
and go back to the east and just
continue being that charismatic self
sword then there's bran stark I do think
that he'll survive but just like Arya
he'll pay a heavy price for his powers I
think he'll just become more weird more
invalid and more powerful working our
way down to the biggest desk I obviously
think that the mountain is going to die
at the hands of the Hound the dream of
cleganebowl is alive I think that beric
Dondarrion is definitely going to eat it
at the hands of the night king it'll be
a spectacular death because he's a fire
white just like George are Martin talked
about a white raised by fire
so I'm really hoping that they have a
plan to kill the night king that fails
and Barrack dies during that attempt and
some spectacular ball of fire I
definitely think the comedy pirate euron
greyjoy is gonna die at the hands of
Theon as he's trying to rescue Yara
that'll be sort of the final step in
Theon reclaiming himself although not
completely making himself whole
killing Huron won't give him his bits
back but it will help actualize him as a
character and like he said yara is our
queen so I don't think the Theon's ever
going to sit in the sea stone chair
but then as Melisandre said at the
beginning of the clip that I included in
this I have to return here to die in
this strange land I definitely think
she's going to accomplish that goal
along with Faris she was telling him in
no uncertain terms that she foresaw
their death and while she has been wrong
in the past I don't think that she's
wrong in this case then I'll say you
know sort of a comedy pick is the golden
companies elephants r.i.p elephants is
just too cool to think about the idea of
the night King turning elephants into
whites so even though Cersei and taiko
and estores were hyping them up I feel
like they're not gonna be long for this
world you'll see them they'll be really
cool and then one of them will get
turned into a white and you'll see a
marching next to the other big giants
Cersei and Jaime are also relatively
high on my list I do hope that Jaime
crawls out but I feel like he's already
narrated his death I want to die in the
arms of someone that I love so I feel
like after he served his purpose helping
them defeat the night king and after
Cersei has died he will also get that
ending but obviously I still believe
that Cersei is going to die in a
metaphorical fulfillment of the valonqar
the little one that's a bit of a
separate video because of the main
characters that are still alive right
now there's still a number that could
fulfill that in a meaningful way for
both Cersei and them but then obviously
I think that they will defeat the night
king so I'll say the night king the
whites and all the White Walkers will
wind up dying whether or not there's
ever the potential for them to return in
the future you know I feel like the
children of the forest have a certain
magical power whether or not they're all
dead by the end of the story doesn't
completely mean that magic will leave
the story so somebody couldn't come
along in another thousand years and
create another night king but then
obviously biggest death predictions are
both Jon Snow and Daenerys because I
feel like when it comes to actually
defeating the night king literally to
beat him there are a number of people
that will have to work together to
execute a plan so when you say kill the
night king everybody's gonna play a role
on that but very specifically there are
a couple of people the Song of Ice and
Fire
that I think you'll ultimately be able
to give credit to so I do believe that
there is a prophecy about Daenerys
becoming pregnant again with
Snow's baby they hinted at it at several
points during this season I can't have
children who told you that there weren't
you mad at my husband hasn't occurred to
you she might not have been a reliable
source of information I've already done
a video about that I'll link it at the
end of this so I do believe that their
potential future child would survive on
if Daenerys does not but of the two of
them I believe that Jon Snow will
sacrifice himself to save everyone but I
will be blown away at the thought that
the nears could live to old age and I
know a lot of people are asking about
the Dragons they can mate with each
other so I do believe there will be
dragon eggs but there's a lot of hoops
that you have to jump through in order
to get to that point like if they died
do their dragons die like when Starks
die usually their direwolves die with
them so you'd have to add ghosts to that
list but I also believe that ragle is
going to become Jon Snow's new dragon so
there are a lot of things up in the air
but let me know in the comments who are
the biggest characters you think will
survive and the biggest characters you
think will die and if there are any
specific characters that I haven't done
videos for yet that you want me to just
let me know in the comments but will
happen is is next week a lot of you been
asking for Melisandre video what's going
on with the red priests what's she doing
in the east there'll be more character
videos so say congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner wispy wispy
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there for the season 7
DVDs now all you have to do to enter the
giveaway just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video I'll announce a
new winner when I post new Game of
Thrones so you can click here to see all
the reasons why Daenerys can probably
become pregnant again and you can click
here for all my season 8 videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight